hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain an American suspenseful
survival movie called teacher
the film Begins by showing a man who
wakes up from his unconsciousness named
Jackson looks like he just had an
accident he immediately looks around but
there is no sunlight at all in other
words his car was already buried in the
ground he tries to open his car door but
his efforts are in vain because the door
is blocked frantically he tries to call
9-1-1 but unfortunately his cell phone
signal is not connecting at all he then
tries to find a radio frequency but it
is also not detected he also tries to
start the car's engine but the car has
already broken down
not long after there is a shock that
causes the car to move deeper he thinks
if there is a shock like this then he is
sure that he wasn't buried in the flat
ground he also records himself using his
cell phone as a form of information in
case he cannot be saved later feeling
pessimistic about the situation he
doesn't know what to do he also hopes
that the rescue team will soon find out
about this incident currently the clock
is showing 1pm indicating that there is
still a chance he will be saved
he then tries to remember what happened
as he is drawing his journey on the
notebook at first everything was fine on
the trip but there was an incident that
suddenly happened to him causing his car
to get buried underground then he
realizes the sunroof has started to
crack due to the enormous pressure of
the ground obviously that is not a good
thing especially since he can only stay
in his car and cannot do anything the
air conditioner can only emit dust
making red ants under the car through
the hole he immediately covers the hole
with masking tape
he panics even more because until now
there is no sign that he will be saved
feeling depressed he decides to watch
the video on his cell phone his fiancee
Laurie is seen in the video after that
he plans to sleep while conserving his
cell phone battery long story short he
wakes up from his sleep and he realizes
that it is already 9 pm he has been
waiting underground for about eight
hours but there is still no sign of help
coming for him Jack who is starting to
get short of breath tries to find an
opening so he can breathe freely when he
opens his car window the dirt spills out
and gets inside the soil texture is also
still wet and soft indicating a Mudslide
meanwhile the cracks in his sunroof are
getting worse he immediately patches the
glass with the masking tape he also uses
a steering wheel lock to hold the mass
off the ground
fortunately the way he does it is quite
effective he then unconsciously drinks
the water until it runs out
he just realizes that it is the only
water he currently has he starts to pray
at that time when he finishes he
realizes that praying alone is not
enough but he has to do his best to get
out of there suddenly he gets an idea to
check his luggage and find some useful
things he initially drinks the water
dripping from the ground back then he
doesn't care whether the water is safe
to drink or not he then makes a small
hole in the sunroof to hold the water in
his Empty Bottle it feels very bad as
Jack has to pee in his own car
soon he takes some parts from his car
seat to make some iron pipes he then
makes another hole in the sunroof to
allow the pipes to penetrate upwards
Jack takes the bottle cap to make a hole
in it and ties it with rope to keep the
pipe straight up before continuing with
his work he eats the only biscuit to
stifle his hunger he also drinks the
contaminated water that has been
accommodated earlier after eating he
continues to push the pipe up the
depletion of oxygen forces him to make a
hole for breathing after seeing the
light outside he immediately checks the
depth of the ground with the Rope he
made before apparently the ground above
is approximately three meters deep he
shouts as loudly as he can with hope
that someone will hear him as he
breathes through the hole then he has
another idea by making smoke through the
pipe so the smoke can be seen by the
others but then the Fire gets bigger and
out of control fortunately he still can
extinguish the fire when he wants to
check the hole there is another shock
that makes his head hit the iron pipe
making him unconscious for a while
shortly after he wakes up with a sore
head he immediately removes his shirt
and belt as a bandage to stop the
bleeding as the result he can only sit
limply thinking of ways to survive a few
hours later Jack's head wound is seen
oozing pus indicating that the wound is
infected suddenly there is another shock
that makes the back of his car begin to
collapse inevitably he has to hold up
the back of his car with the rest of the
iron pipes Jack who feels very thirsty
has to drink his own urine he then takes
the car tires and plugs it into the pump
hose to keep him breathing from the air
inside the tire in desperation he
decides to dig the ground above him to
get out of the place he also applies oil
all over his body to keep it slippery
when it penetrates the hard ground this
decision is made purposely by him to
survive even though he is not sure
either furthermore he immediately
destroys the sunroof so the ground above
it can descend into his car while
carrying the car tires to breathe Jack
slowly tries to dig up the ground at
some point he is finally able to stand
on top of his car on the other hand the
air in the car tires is Getting Thinner
but suddenly for the umpteenth time
there is another shot that makes his
whole body covered with dirt amazingly
there is little movement that indicates
Jack is still alive after a long time he
manages to reach the ground and he also
can see the sunlight again in the end he
manages to survive the mudslide he has
just experienced
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching